gulliver crac bonjour vous êtes notre
correspondant sur place un déplacement
qui intervient après l annonce de
londres de vouloir doubler sur place ses
effectifs militaires c'était le week-end
dernier qu'est-ce qu'il faut attendre de
plus aujourd'hui
alors en plus de l'aide militaire boris
johnson va annoncer aujourd'hui plus de
100 millions d'euros en aides
supplémentaires pour aider l'ukraine
avec ses réformes de gouvernance et
notamment pour améliorer son
indépendance énergétique
voilà pour ce qu'il y a en terme
d'annoncé nouvelle mais le royaume uni a
déjà augmenté son aide militaire à
l'ukraine en termes à la fois dead et
deux contre un militaire il ya notamment
contrat pour leur développement de la
marine ukrainienne d'une valeur de plus
de 1
milliard et demi d'euros et les armes
qui ont déjà été envoyées le mois
dernier par londres à kiev notamment des
missiles anti tank l'ukraine est très
reconnaissante envers le royaume uni
d'avoir réagi aussi rapidement et
d'avoir tout de suite envoyé ses armes
donc je pense que c'est le cas de dire
que boris johnson en ce moment est
beaucoup beaucoup plus populaire à kiev
qu'il l'est à londres où il est encore
il est en course et ses déboires
politiques autour des fêtes s'est tenue
à downing street
a
clairement demandé à l'ukraine de quoi
là elle a besoin
aujourd'hui boris johnson qui a décalé
son entretien téléphonique ça fait
beaucoup de coups de fil en ce moment
avec vladimir poutine lui parlera demain
on renvoie bien gulliver les
britanniques qui sont clairement sur la
même ligne que washington ait compris
pour les sanctions envisagées à l'égard
des rues st
oui ils sont sur la même ligne que
washington sur l'ukraine non seulement
sur la question des sanctions mais aussi
sur la question de quelle est la
priorité de vladimir poutine est ce sa
vanité des rétablir un contrôle sur
l'ukraine en terme de sanction les
parlementaires britanniques doivent
voter cette semaine sur une nouvelle loi
qui permettra d'appliquer des sanctions
aux proches de vladimir poutine qu'il
soit directement impliqué dans l'action
de la russie à l'égard de l'ukraine ou
non et aussi bien sûr il y a eu beaucoup
de choses qui ont été dites sur l'argent
sale russe à londres l'utilisation par
les russes deux agences financières et
d'avocats à londres les activistes anti
corruption depuis des années supplique
n'aurait hominid faire quelque chose
pour agir contre cela ils disent
qu'aujourd'hui les mesures annoncées
sont un pas dans la bonne direction mais
un tout petit pas et pour vraiment faire
quelque chose d'efficace il faudrait
faire beaucoup plus voilà les
britanniques qui ne sont pas les seuls à
assumer en faveur d'une désescalade
merci beaucoup gulliver craque